thank you
so I'd like to get started here in a
second
much
okay it being two o'clock uh we're gonna
go ahead and get started with the work
session on division three on finance we
have uh four bills to uh listen to the
uh the public and to discuss a little
bit uh there is an order that was
suggested in the calendar with the
permission of Representative nordgren
I'd like to change up the sequence uh
they're all scheduled for two anyways
I'd like to just change this sequence
based on who we've got here who are
prepared to speak like for example first
up is 6 14 and representative rung is
here from Merrimack
are you okay with we going by 6 14 282
565 and 91 in that order
all right thank you so representative
wrong welcome to division three
thank you very much Mr chair and and
Madam Vice chair for accommodating my
schedule for the record my name is
Rosemary rung and I represent
Hillsborough 12 which is the town of
Merrimack I'm here on behalf of the
Prime sponsor representative Nancy
Murphy who is not able to be here to
introduce hb2 uh I'm sorry uh
6 14. I'm sorry about that
um but and
um I've served on the HB 737 commission
for the past four years and for the last
two of those I've been uh chairman up
until December and one of the things
this commission does is we are charged
with looking at the health and
environmental impacts of pfas
contamination stemming from the senko
Bain
operations in Merrimack and one every
year we submit an annual report to the
governor the Senate President the
speaker of the house and and a few other
folks with our legislative and
non-legislative recommendations and this
past year when we submitted our report
in November one of those recommendations
was to conduct a a cancer registry for
cancer that has been demonstrated to be
linked to pfas Expo closure
and after discussions with
DHHS
we introduced this bill to as a
feasibility study because what occurred
a little over a year ago is
dhh DHHS had conducted a cancer study a
cancer incident study and they
discovered that Merrimack has a
significantly higher rate of renal
cancer kidney cancer than what would be
expected and there's a four-phase
approach to analyzing these types of
diseases and linkages and we've
completed phase one and two but this
expenditure 500 000 would allow DHHS to
go into the next phase phase three which
is a feasibility study and
representative why I remember your
comments on Friday when I introduced to
12 about the importance of having these
types of studies to really understand
the causation of pfas contamination on
human health and so this is
the result of that this is what happens
next so I implore you to
um support the funding for this bill not
only will it provide information to the
town of Merrimack and our residents but
also to other communities that have
suffered from pfas exposure
um just the ones in our area include
Bedford Litchfield and Londonderry but
there's also significant exposure in the
Seacoast area from the peas trade Port
so information from this phase three
study can be leveraged to so many other
areas not just for more understanding
about the impact of pfax exposure on
human health but also just going through
that academic process can enable us to
DHS to be better equipped to understand
other environmentally triggered diseases
I'm very happy to be joined today by
Michelle Roberge who's the division
director division Chief at for public
health at DHHS and also Ms Abby Rogers
who is the legislative liaison she's
worked very closely with us she's also
worked with representative Leon from
Derry who worked on an amendment to this
bill which allows DHS to pursue grants
to precede any
appropriation by the by the legislature
so if you don't mind Mr chairman if
there's any questions they would
probably be better able to answer them
from a financial process point of view I
I'm okay with that but before we let you
go is there anyone here that wants to
ask representative a question go
ahead
all right thanks representative wrong
thank you just a quick question and this
could wait if this if you don't know the
answer to this question is when I read
that it's limited to kidney cancer I was
curious as to why it wasn't going it's
not expanded to other cancers is that
limiting it at all I'm just was
wondering why it's just kidney well uh
thank you for the question
representative the kidney cancer renal
cancer which would be bundled in with
that is what was demonstrated from the
phase two study that it was
significantly higher and so the focus of
the feasibility study would be on that
cancer the other cancers although some
kind of approached a level that would
require further study they didn't
um but kidney cancer did but I'm sure
someone from DHS may be able to give a
better a more specific response to that
you ever follow-up all right so you're
welcome to stay there while the other
two come forward or you can set back
whatever you want I'll step back a
representative erf thank you thank you
to my question uh two things how long
will it take and can you describe what a
phase three study is
with all due respect representative I
thank you very much for that question
but I think the folks from DHHS could
give a more accurate response
very very good thanks okay thank you
thank you again
folks from the Department want to come
up
so we'll start with introductions so
that representative Stringham can get it
for the record
my name is Michelle Roberge I'm the
bureau chief of Public Health action
within the Department of Health and
Human Services Division of Public Health
Services
hello I'm Whitney Hammond I'm the
section administrator for the chronic
disease prevention and screening section
in the division of Public Health
Services which includes the cancer
program
hi I'm Dr Kathleen Bush I'm the sex and
chief of environmental Public Health
tracking within the division of Public
Health Services
but I I have probably five or six
questions but I'll defer if anyone has
wants to kick us off
all right so
um
so for this study the biggest
expenditure by far is the I.T spend
portion of it is that correct the
information technology go ahead
um I believe that that might be the
physical note was updated
um so it doesn't have an I.T component
anymore it it's the appropriation is for
five hundred thousand dollars and it
would be for a contract that the
department would enter into a contract
I was given
several amendments on oh wait a second
one Amendment on 565 we're on 614.
there we go I'm getting better at this
okay so it's now a half a million
dollars
is for one contracted full-time
statistical research analyst one
Community engagement specialist
and then Community engagement activities
along with some miscellaneous equipment
and indirect costs is that right is that
you're understanding what you what you
need yes that's correct and I think uh
represent tolerski hit the nail on the
head already asking about
the extent to which we want to study
more I think the legislature is just
generally concerned about water quality
in the Merrimack area and all the health
risks that we believe is non-scientists
even could stem from that and and so if
we're going to go forward and and and
really pay attention is this program
scoped sufficiently for the public risk
so the department
of
take a crack at this and then I'm sure
my colleagues can fill in around me
around the information that I provide
today so as representative rung noted in
her testimony that the department has
been has an ongoing investigation in the
Merrimack area for kidney cancer
incidents an increase in kidney cancer
incidents in that area and we are using
our protocol so New Hampshire has a
cancer concern investigation protocol
and she mentioned various phases in that
protocol so we have gone through phases
one and two and based on the analysis
that we have done and and the results of
that that indicate that the increase in
kidney cancer incidence is we recommend
going to phase three and that phase
three if you look at our protocol is a
feasibility study and really what that
is is it's Gathering it's it's gathering
in information and doing an analysis to
determine whether or not the risk
factors are there to go into what would
be called a phase four or a full
epidemiological study of of uh you know
the the kidney cancer and the potential
exposures to the area so we're kind of
in that in between you know not ready to
go do a full phase for study but looking
at the next step would be which would be
phase three a feasibility study
so this is coming by way of of the
policy committee and maybe this would
have been a good representative wrong
question do what what what was the
policy committee's position on this was
this unanimous close to unanimous were
there what were the big issues left
outstanding
Health Human Service and elderly Affairs
committee and I believe it was a 19-1 or
eight it was
oh 19-0 as amended
ought to pass and it uh went uh it
passed the Full House on the consent
calendar
thank you representative hole
thank you chairman so you're speaking of
phase three and phase four for those who
are not familiar with your protocols
um can you just briefly describe phase
one phase two right as it feeds into the
system
foreign
so phase one is um usually just when we
receive a sort of request or concern
from the community or from a legislative
committee
um that's where we just collect
information about what the concern is
and
um kind of just do a first pass at
whether there's anything plausible to
look into
phase two is if we determine there is
something and just as an example phase
one a lot of times
my staff will receive phone call like a
phone call from a Community member
saying I'm seeing lots of different
cancers among you know people living on
my street and we've all lived here for
you know decades and this is really
concerning and at that point we would
potentially gather information about
what types of cancers they are seeing in
their neighbors and a lot of times this
is very common you know you might have
breast cancer colorectal cancer
prostate cancer and at that point we
might just do some education around that
the those are all really different types
of cancers with different types of risk
factors they're screening amenable and
they're age related so most I'd say 97
of concerns end at that point
with just basic education sometimes and
an example that has come up in the last
couple of years you might get a phone
call from somebody who's working at a
school and they feel like they're seeing
lots and lots of cases of breast cancer
among the teachers that have been
working there and for example they're
seeing them in 30 year olds and so that
kind of checks off a couple of the boxes
for us where we say well 30 is a little
bit you know early to be seeing cases of
breast cancer and oh it's in you know it
is one type of cancer as opposed to
several different ones so in phase two
so if we saw that kind of a pattern we'd
go to phase two which is where we look
at our cancer registry data and analyze
and maybe look at things like breast
cancer rates in a community so that's
what we had done in Merrimack which is
what identified the higher than expected
number of kidney Cancers and then phase
three is really part of the challenge
for us is that our cancer registry does
not collect a lot of additional
information about individuals who are
diagnosed with cancer so we don't get
things like the history of where a
person has lived for their entire life
all we have is their address at the
point when they're diagnosed with a
cancer
we also don't get information as as
surprising as it might be we don't
capture things like smoking history or
other known risk factors for certain
cancers
so when we have a situation like we have
in Merrimack
um we have to actually gather additional
information from people to even get a
sense of is there some sort of a
hypothesis we could make so for example
in Merrimack without knowing people's
residential history you could actually
have a lot of people that were diagnosed
with kidney cancer a month after they
moved there that's probably not likely
but that's part of what the feasibility
study is going to try and gather
information to suss out and then do you
want phase four and then phase four
would be a really sort of bigger
undertaking we call it an
epidemiological study it's probably what
people are most familiar with in terms
of how things are researched and tested
and could include something like a case
control study where you really compare
exposures between people who have that
Health outcome of kidney cancer and
those who don't
that was very helpful so if you proceed
from a phase three to a phase four is
there a time where you start looking at
residents of other towns who did reside
in
um Merrimack who now live in Bosco in or
somewhere else right up in the Lakes
Region so how do you do you then look at
data from where people move
I would say even in phase three
um one of the first steps for that phase
is to create what we call a case
definition and in that case definition
we would even start to look at probably
people who had lived in Merrimack for
some period of time and may have moved
and then been diagnosed with kidney
cancer and we have a national network of
cancer Registries so we can reach out to
partner States and try and you know
identify who those individuals are
representative Weiler
thank you Mr chair
where would I find the results of phase
one and phase two are they online
somewhere
in the HHS site yes you would find the
results on the department's website
um
I don't know exactly where on the cancer
program web page cancer program website
further question
are you going to do
wide-ranging amongst the population to
see blood tests see if other people
will you be able to determine from blood
tests the amount of of pfas within blood
streams in a representative group is
that part of it
so I think the the first step was if we
if this bill moves forward when we get
the appropriation is we would want to
establish a contract with a research
organization as as Whitney noted to
start to begin to design what the study
will look like what exactly is going to
be included in the study we do know that
it will be uh you know working with the
community and impacted individuals there
will be a need for recruitment to
determine to say right here and now I
don't know that we could specifically
say exactly what will be involved in the
study but at a minimum we would want to
be doing recruitment with impacted
individuals working with
impacted the impacted Community to
determine you know as as uh Miss Hammond
noted it to determine
how long have the people been in those
areas have they actually been exposed to
pfas you know what what is their
drinking water have they can you know
sort of that risk picture what is the
risk picture for the individuals that we
know of so we can't answer that today to
say that there would be blood testing or
I think we'd want to work with our um
our research organization to figure out
what exactly does this study look like I
am also interested in another exposed
group firemen who are spraying this
stuff out of the hoses and perhaps
getting a study going on them if you
could find out from whoever contracts
with you if that's possible something
that and it would probably do it
Statewide representative samples and
people that have been a fireman for at
least 10 years and have some exposure to
this I wonder what how much further we
could go in in doing something like that
so we see Statewide what the exposure
might be
I can't speak to National initiatives
but certainly just like we would explore
residential history we would also be
gathering information on occupational
history and what people have done for
work over time to explore Trends in
occupation and I think all of that then
feeds together into a potential you know
phase four study and building I do think
this was producing a foundation for
future work
thank you thank you Mr chairman uh
representative Moon
thank you and thank you all for being
here and for all the work you've done to
this point on this very serious issue my
question is how often is it that a phase
two
would become a phase three and the
purpose for the question is to highlight
the severity of this circumstance in my
community and the surrounding area thank
you
so I can tell you I've been in my this
position for the last decade
um we probably receive
um I don't 40 40 inquiries you know a
year
um probably like I said around 90
percent of those go are just phase one
we provide education maybe 10 of those
go go on to phase two where we use our
data and actually calculate you know
look at different things
and then it has only this would be the
second time in 10 years that we had come
to the conclusion based on our analysis
and sort of you know plausibility and
Community concerns that this should go
to phase three so very seldom
so you mentioned that representative
Leon put together this amendment and
she's very thorough but I just I want I
just want to check the logic on this
because immediately you want to begin
with two very different types of
employees
um and I it just makes me wonder should
should one come before the other or
should they actually be on Parallel
tracks and then the beyond that is are
these redundant with other things we're
doing in the department to where we
don't need a dedicated full-time person
but we do need a Time slice of somebody
so so we've got somebody who's expert at
statistical research we've got community
engagement I understand why you would
need to have both I'm just curious if
one really logically precedes the other
in a project plan and if we really need
manpower to fully fund both of them as
full-time employees
yeah I'm happy to start start to answer
that question so
um currently right now the way the
appropriation sort of that we're
envisioning the use of the appropriation
would be to contract with
um an organization like a research or an
academic organization because we just
don't have the
um
technical expertise or the existing
resources to be able to put time the
time needed towards this project so the
first you are right that it's two
positions one is a full-time would be a
full-time research analyst position that
would be sort of the lead of this
project the second position is actually
a part-time position it would be the
community engagement specialist because
this work is so because Community
engagement is so critical that both of
these positions are really necessary you
know the the Project Lead the the lead
analyst would be you know responsible
for leading the project conducting a
scientific literature review developing
the study design study implementation
data analysis analysis and things like
that the community engagement specialist
would be really working with impacted
individuals families communities
we follow a national guidance from CDC
Centers for Disease Control on how to
conduct a cancer concern investigation
which really stresses the need for
Community engagement and working with
local officials and you know policy
makers so we would this would be a very
transparent process and and I will say
that in order for this to be successful
study recruitment so we really need
people impacted people people that have
kidney cancer that live in the area or
have lived in the area to agree to
participate in the study because without
that study recruitment we wouldn't have
any information we wouldn't discern any
information from the phase three study
so it's super critical that we have that
Community engagement person to really
work with the community to build trust
within the community and and recruit for
the study
so thank you for that I'm I'm about to
let you go if there are no other
questions
do you have a question still I do thank
you all right if I pulled up the report
thank you for telling us where it was I
see why you guys focused on kidney and
renal pelvis right based on the numbers
in the prior report my question is
regarding two other areas looking at
that same data column and rectum start
with writing an sir 1.2 going up to 1.43
and there was one other
similar in nature right urinary bladder
seen similar numbers where right the
entire the entire spectrum is north of
one is there a reason those were
excluded I mean I understand the kidney
side I get that that's easy from the
data the engineering me loves looking at
this but there's two others that seem to
crop up as well why would they not be
included if you're doing this research
so I I can't recall the specific numbers
in the chart but you probably have them
in front of you the the key difference
for kidney cancer versus those other two
types of cancer that you referenced are
related to the confidence intervals so
when we look at what's called the
standardized incidence ratio we look at
whether it's one or greater than one so
you picked out like colorectal was 1.2
we also look at the confidence intervals
and if the lower confidence interval is
above one then we would it's the ones I
picked out yeah oh uh there shouldn't be
any other cancer types that are above so
colon was one to 1.43 so if it's urinary
bladder was 0.98 to 1.49 so so not above
not one technically above but on the
very edge and vastly different than the
others in that same list of cancers
thank you for that as epidemiologist I
appreciate that
um I would just add that based on the
evolving scientific literature of what
we know between exposure and outcomes
the literature really suggests a strong
scientific evidence of a link to kidney
cancer where the others are really still
emerging and I think this gets back to
representative tellerski's question
around other outcomes part of the study
will also investigate co-occurring
outcomes so we'll look at risk factors
and the co-occurrence of some of these
things and again it will build a
foundation for future work for us to
better understand a range of Health
outcomes that may be related to
exposures that we're observing in this
community
do you have to follow up do you have one
represents Stringham yeah just um in in
terms of Contracting for this I assume
you're going to have to work through the
contracts group here when do you think
uh reasonably how long would it take for
you to go from uh laying out the project
to actually having the two contractors
ready to go
I
um I so I would give a range of two
months to six months depending on you
know who was identified as the vendor to
do the work we do have an existing
contract for cancer registry and we have
used that contract for similar types of
work so if we were to use an existing
contract it would like I said be two to
six months
all right so
um if if I were a Merrimack
representative I I would like you to
periodically touch base with me to let
me know how we're doing from a community
perspective how big of a
sample size of the total population n
ought to be and how we're doing at the
community engagement level you know if
we're have if we're struggling with uh
with just not doing well on the
community engagement level I would I
would think people would want to know
that so although if we if we pass this
and give you the money there's nothing
in here that requires any periodic
reporting I would just recommend you
keep people informed
absolutely and just to let you know so
there is an existing commission it's
it's called the HB 737 Commission in
Merrimack in particular and surrounding
communities but we are a member
DHHS sits on the commission and it meets
on a monthly basis so we would certainly
provide periodic updates probably on a
monthly basis to the commission and and
I believe most of the Merrimack or
several Merrimack Representatives sit on
the commission as well
okay
um I'm I'm ready to do a last call here
is there anyone else in the audience
that wants to speak on this particular
bill
and not seeing any thank you very much
thank you for your time uh we're going
to move on to uh I believe 282 is next
uh representative Shapiro you're among
the people that are I'm anticipating
will want to speak
is is there is there anyone else here to
speak to 282 that I should know about be
aware of
you are we why don't you just come up
now
we'll do this
family style
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
committee members I'm Joe Shapiro
representing Cheshire 16 Keen
um I assume that all of you or most of
you heard me speak on this bill in the
house and so I'll try to keep it brief
um
in 1996 there was a major welfare
welfare reform bill passed under
President Clinton and it included
creating waiting periods for certain
federal benefits so one of those waiting
periods was for certain classes of
immigrants
in order to be eligible to apply for
Medicaid
in 2009 the chip reauthorization
bill under the federal government
created an option for states to waive
that five-year waiting period for
certain groups of lawfully residing
immigrants
um
that states could take
um and um
amend their Medicaid State plan to
include that and as you'll see on the
map that I sent around
35 States for
um
for children in 37 States for pregnant
women have taken that option or created
some other kind of option for coverage
for lawfully residing immigrants
um
so
I think this is a good bill I think this
is something New Hampshire should have
for several reasons
um one is it's an investment in families
it's an investment in young children and
um pregnant women we can't always agree
about
issues like abortion but I think we all
tend to agree that families should get
the help they need to get a good start
in life and this will take a select
group of people just children
and pregnant women
from immigrant families who are lawfully
residing in New Hampshire
and provide them with the opportunity to
apply for Medicaid if they're otherwise
eligible in other words if by income
they're eligible then they would not
have this five-year wait this bill would
waive the five-year wait
I think the reasons that this is a good
bill and that we should proceed with
this is that it's investment in the
health and wellness of children families
um
we have a tremendous Workforce shortage
in New Hampshire and all around the
country really and I don't expect that
immigrants coming to New Hampshire are
going to solve the workforce shortage
but I think they're uh an element of of
helping with that
um in researching this bill I spoke to
the vice president at pitco friellator
which I'd never heard of but evidently
they make friolaters for McDonald's all
over the world and they're located in
Concord and they have a large
manufacturing Workforce and during covid
and since covid they've really been
hurting they can't find people to hire
people have left and so when I spoke to
the vice president there he said that
someone had suggested to them that they
hire a few Afghan evacuees who were
resettled in Concord so they hired four
afghan evacuees that had come to Concord
and they did such a good job that when I
spoke to this fellow
in December he said they had hired 40
Afghan
evacuees and that they were looking to
figure out how they could create a
prayer room since most of these um
Afghans or Muslim and pray five times a
day so they were they were outfitting uh
a prayer room so that they could
um keep good relations with these
employers so once again I don't think
this is a bill that's going to attract a
lot of people to immigrants to New
Hampshire
um but at least we won't be hanging a
sign out saying that you're not welcome
here
um
another reason that this is a good bill
I think is that
um
when people don't have health care
insurance
um
frequently people go without Health Care
sometimes they put off getting health
care until the problems are more serious
and they end up in the emergency room or
with um a bigger problems and I think
this bill will once again this is a
small Bill affecting very few people
about 300 people
but this bill will help with
unreimbursed costs that now
um our health care providers just have
to eat or
um well I can say in Keen they I don't
think they think of it as just that
they're eating these costs they've come
forward and um want to encourage people
in our community to get health care and
they want to encourage the community to
be welcoming one for immigrants so um we
have a project in Keene that works with
Asylum Seekers and
um many of these people have been
getting health care but the but it's not
paid for
um
so let me just say who would be
um who would be eligible for this
five-year weight being waived I sent
around
I'll tell you I've researched this for
two years and it is so complicated and
so hard for me to understand and I found
this one woman in Los Angeles who works
for a national immigration law Center
who helps me to understand but I still
cannot say that I fully understand all
the different kind of categories we tend
to think of immigration as
binary either people are
documented or they're not documented but
when in reality it's not a binary system
there are all different Shades of Gray
they're all different they're all
different categories of people being
here with different rights and benefits
and the main group of people that would
be covered through this
would be people who come through family
unification
and are either about to get their Green
Card who are or have just gotten their
green card
people who come through temporary
protected status which is um when there
has been some kind of major
environmental or war in a particular
country and people from that country are
given temporary protected status
another group that this would affect
um are people who are seeking Asylum so
if someone comes to this country
they pass an initial interview which is
called a credible fear interview and
then they're allowed to apply for
um Asylum
they're usually given a hearing a year
two years
sometimes more off in the future
and
for those people when the children have
been here for 180 days they would fit in
this category they would be able to
apply for Medicaid if they otherwise
were eligible and for adults it would be
a halfway process halfway in the process
when they get a work a work permit
um
what else do I want to say um
I I'll say a couple of things about
um
I'll say a couple of things about
the ability for us to adapt this bill
um but um Mr Lipman who's in the back
would be better able to answer these
questions
um my understanding that this bill and
the bill that's going to come up
um next or one after that 565. these are
federal options so they're options it's
not something that I thought of or
someone on our committee thought of
these are federal options and it's kind
of like you take it or you don't take it
um
and in order to actually adapt it to New
Hampshire or adapt it to some other idea
that we might have which may be a good
idea
you can apply to do that but
um it involves a particular kind of
waiver that is very extent expensive to
pursue and to keep track of once you got
it probably more than the money you
would save so if we're looking for
savings and um
I've been told by Mr lippman better to
put off the effective date than to try
to get a waiver to change the specifics
and with that I'll I'll stop
glad to take any questions
let's go on with testimony and then
we'll just take questions after go ahead
thank you thank you Mr chair members of
the committee I'm Bob Dunn the director
of public policy for the Roman Catholic
Diocese of Manchester and I'm here today
on behalf of Bishop Peter labashi in
support of both House Bill 282 and House
Bill 565 the postpartum bill that you're
going to hear next and I would to save
time I would say ditto
um and I would just say that the reason
that we think that these bills are
important are that they're pro-life
bills
um they enhance the quality of life they
save lives potentially and so um we
think that uh it that they really should
happen it's a very limited number of
people as you've heard on both sides of
this and Mr lippman can speak about that
in more detail but um these are the
sorts of bills that we think enhance the
common good in human dignity and that's
why we support them thank you
questions representative order no
anyone
um
I I just want to have an observation
uh I I I really appreciate your
testimony representative Shapiro
referring uh to the pregnant women and I
think it's ridiculous that we have a
chart here that refers to pregnant
people I mean we we should follow the
science by now women get pregnant and
have babies
it's not even worth commenting on other
than I I think on in defense of the
language and in defensive science we
ought to just acknowledge reality so I I
would like to comment on that which is
that
um that is a map that I got from a
National Organization that tracks these
things and if you notice my bill says
pregnant women it does not say pregnant
people and that's why thank you thank
you
are there any other ques representative
Weiler yes what we have encountered in
the last several years is a huge
increase in monies being paid out to
Immigrant families coming here and
perhaps the reason for the delay in New
Hampshire is we could have a just
someone fly in have a baby fly back out
and a few years later do this chain
migration bit with people that weren't
really concerned about getting a job as
much as they were concerned about
getting
public benefits and that's been one of
the skyrocketing costs in our country
that we have to be aware of because it
soon becomes a burden that's
unaffordable if we have too many people
thinking we're a magnet for welfare so
it's not something we'd rush into thank
you
can I can I comment on that
um
I I understand that immigration is a
terrible problem in our country and that
the system is broken and that um
it's unsustainable what's happening in
this country so many people being here
working
contributing
no way to be acknowledged no way to be
um no way to have a path um towards
citizenship more people come in it's I I
would agree I'd be the first one to
agree with you that it's chaos it's
broken it's a real problem
um and so this bill in no way tries to
fix the problem it just
um
it just takes what is and tries to
address one very very tiny
um portion of it and in response to
people taking advantage of benefits
I I understand that argument we had a
person who couldn't come because her
um because she was working but we had
one person give testimony
um written testimony and someone read it
in our hearing she is a woman originally
from Africa
came with her husband and two children
and was pregnant and came to Texas
initially
she um in Texas they have these benefits
so she was pregnant and she had Medicaid
and was going to deliver the baby in in
Texas her husband was detained at the
Stratford County Jail
and um so she moved her family here her
two young children and um
and her pregnant self only to find that
New Hampshire we have not taken this
option she had no health care she was
about to deliver a baby she got some
community support and was fixed up with
um charity Health Care
um
currently when she wrote the letter
currently she's had a child her husband
is out of detention they've both now had
their hearing for Asylum and they've
both been granted Asylum she works she
has gotten her LNA she's working in a
nursing home and she's now in nursing
school to become a nurse so I understand
your concern that
people will be a burden and I'm not
saying that there aren't some people
that will be a burden but people are
also an enormous resource in terms of
some of the things that we need in New
Hampshire
I wonder how the husband ended up in
jail here if the family was in Texas
well I could I could answer you but um
it doesn't make any sense it doesn't
make any sense
is that a rhetorical question just the
way it is so representative Minnie thank
you and thank you for being here I know
how dedicated you are to this subject
matter representative my question is
I've heard you several times now refer
to the five-year waiver I'm just trying
to piece that into this bill as I don't
see that language here is that a chipra
tie-in or how does that five-year waiver
if you could just briefly
describe that not a five-year waiver a
five-year wait so if you oh I'm sorry I
thought you said if you um
have this and I'm glad I asked me but
you have this CMS guidance this was
something that CMS sent out
um following the year following when the
option was created and it explains it
all so currently many classes of
immigrants have to wait five years to be
eligible to apply for Medicaid even if
their income indicates that they are
eligible so if this option is taken if
an amendment is written to the State
Medicaid plan
just for children and pregnant women who
are lawfully residing here who have some
kind of lawful immigration status that
five-year wait will be waived
that's what this bill does
representslersky thank you Mr chairman
I'm wondering if um when we're
discussing
people who are resettled here in New
Hampshire
do they actually have a choice are they
ever going to see a map and do research
and say I would like to go to Texas
where pregnant women and children get
services or are they resettled here
based on
you know a governmental uh guidance of
where they're going to be
so once again
[Music]
um
when I said that um
immigration status is not binary it's
not one or the other there are many many
ways that people come to the country and
I think maybe you're referring to people
who are resettled here through a
resettlement agency they're vetted in
some manner the people from Afghanistan
were not vetted as well because
um
it was an emergency obviously and it was
um totally chaotic but people who are
resettled through the state department
like the Afghans or through a number of
people in the Concord area Laconia area
and Manchester they're brought to a
specific place in place and set
resettled through an agency some of the
other groups people who are who are
looking for a green card they might have
come to the area where their relatives
live who were petitioning
um
people who are
coming to request Asylum might have come
a different way so it really varies
depending on how people came and under
what auspices they came thank you I
guess my point was simply there are
reasons why people are placed here and
they don't necessarily go in search of a
certain benefit that would apply to one
person in their family I think that's
safe to say people are just trying to
survive thank you
representative walner
it's probably a question for Mr Lipman
but how long does it take New Hampshire
to do the process of getting a waiver
good afternoon uh good afternoon for the
record Henry Littman Medicaid director
thank you for the question
representative it depends on the type of
wave we're talking about in this
instance we were talking about or in the
instance representative was referring to
as an 11 15 waiver and those
um require an evaluation
um an independent evaluation that
sometimes can run seven figures to be
able to to conduct because it has to be
done over multiple years and hiring
upside research firm it typically has
taken us six months on the short end to
get one of those in place there are
other types of waivers that are can be
done typically in 90 to
180 days
an example would be some of the ones
related to the dental program that are
different types of waivers
a research waiver when you're asking for
an exception from the the policies as
opposed to asking for a waiver for an
established policy that's the difference
when you're asking for an exception from
an existing policy it takes longer than
taking advantage of a policy that's
already in place
thank you so you would anticipate that
this would take probably up to six
months to get this waiver so this type
of waiver would be
um is I think you're asking for a policy
outside of what is the established
policy which could take
um probably
nine six months to a year knowing what I
know about the what's going on with the
with the federal waiver area based on
the work we're doing with
um you know getting everything in place
for dental I think we're on the long
side of this just based on what the
workload that CMS has for example
um
just just adopted in California which
New Hampshire has an interest in as well
in our severely mentally ill and sud
waiver the opportunity to address
justice-involved individuals in terms of
getting Medicaid to pay for some of the
transitional costs
they're just that that waiver alone
many states are interested and it's a
high priority for the administration so
trying to get people to work on
something that is
less of a priority in terms of CMS in
terms of working through their waivers I
think is why I think it'd probably be on
the long end
no I just to follow up
so
at the department you have the resources
right now you could do this because it
sounds like if we're going to do it we
need to get the paperwork done we need
to get the application into CMS as
quickly as possible so I think if if I
could distinguish between
um adopting the policy that's in place
that's in the CMS letter that
representative referred to would be a
shorter process that's that's probably
more like a six-month process I think
the question I was addressing I
apologize if I was not completely
responsive was if we were looking for an
exception or some change from what is
the established policy so it would take
around six months if we adopt this thank
you
yeah just to to make sure that we're
um
we're all understanding the same thing I
don't want to be repetitive but I think
when when Mr lippman talked about the
um
large amount of money and large amount
of waiting time he was talking about and
tell me if I'm wrong it's as if we were
to deviate from the option that we can
just take if we just take the option I
don't think it involves the same amount
of time and certainly not this we don't
have to hire an independent researcher
to to evaluate a different policy than
what is already approved by CMS
yeah thank you
um so when you said seven figures that
was to establish a kind of a new program
uh with a waiver that you know is based
upon this so in budgeting this program
um you know assuming that we're
following uh the established
um
what's allowable
um is the is the budget that we're
talking about in here sufficient to get
going with that so I think that the the
budget
um
and I think we've submitted a
clarification I'm not sure if the the
but we're talking about 336 thousand
dollars for the biennium to cover
if we and that would be the expense for
following the current policy in place
that CMS has for this and and I would
just if I could just add one thing to it
is that people who are lawfully residing
is who what we're talking about
after five years they are going to be
eligible for Medicaid so the issue is is
by not providing The Upfront care are we
in the Medicaid Program assuming they
still continue to live reside in New
Hampshire going to have a higher cost
situation to deal with than if they got
the appropriate preventative care up
front that's why I think the department
supports it because we think that we're
going to own the long-term care and
that's going to be much more expensive
if they haven't had the front end yeah
that's that's Theory though right you
don't have any data on that that's a
supposition that's a supposition
numbers so that we're here in the budget
is primarily um
um you know for for providing the care
for the new recipients and yes not for
uh not for the administration correct to
get the program going yes which
is or is not a big number it would not
be a big number if we adopted the policy
representable
thank you Mr chairman
um I'm looking at the original fiscal
note which was
um 448
per year or total 224 per year you just
mentioned a new one that was 336 I don't
336 for the biennium I don't have a copy
of that so so the fiscal note talks
about
448 thousand dollars per year half of
that is State funds half of that is
federal funds okay and the 336 thousand
dollars was um
put into the bill as an appropriation
through an amendment amendment 0160 I
don't know what you have in front of you
if it includes the amendment or not
um but this was passed through the house
a couple of weeks ago and um the
amendment was just to clarify that we
now had to cover
three quarters of the biennium so
um the number that had been in there
previously was from the bill when it was
introduced last year when there was only
going to be six months of the biennium
um before the bill was effective thank
you
um so there's a casual Observer of a
history on this
a hundred years or so when we were doing
immigration policy
for somebody to immigrate into the
United States so generally needed to
find a sponsor and they would come to
the United States with the commitment
that they wouldn't add to the social
costs
for a long period of time
that policy evolved and for quite a
while we had a five-year wait period and
and I think to represent Weiler's point
the idea was let's put this five-year
wait policy in so that our social
benefits are not a magnet to the world
to get everyone to come here knowing
that they would be entitled the benefits
immediately that's what that five-year
waiting period was for
and so as we've continued from that I
think it was a Clinton administration
that started to chip away at the
five-year waiting period
um
and we've opened up the door
as to
Refugee status
meaning something different than what it
used to mean do we it's now more of a
catch-all phrase where people can
run into
immigration system and declare that
they're in a refugee status and
generally they get accepted and
protected and it's a huge loophole so
for those people
who who look at this and worry that
we're open up Medicaid we've got a
financial crisis that may come upon us
at the federal level we're certainly got
issues at the state level where we have
to manage our money we're opening up and
expanding eligibility here in a way that
really is inconsistent with the history
and while we may do it I don't know we
haven't decided but I I just I just want
to point out that there has been reason
why we've not done it yet you know
so
are there any other questions or
comments
all right okay well thank you for for
stopping by I appreciate it
and we'll move on to HB 565.
are you here for that you're fast
is there anyone here Dr Ballinger you're
going to be speaking on 565 aren't you
okay come on up is there anyone else in
the audience that wants to speak on 565.
okay so representative Mooney is
pointing out that you do have a revised
fiscal note amended the 6th of March on
565.
um go ahead and representative Shapiro
thank you
um
so the first thing I'd like to point out
that um is that house bill 565 is
another Federal option
um we're here to talk about Federal
options Federal Option Day and so this
is another Federal option that was
created by CMS
um
and I will just say that for starters
that um there was a this was part this
identical bill was part of a senate
Omnibus Bill last year that passed the
Senate and passed the house and then
went to a committee of conference and
um
it didn't make it through the committee
of conference but my understanding it
has had nothing to do with this this
part of the Omnibus Bill
um this was not in contention so
we wouldn't be here talking today if
that um if it had been signed last year
so once again this is a bill that um
takes a federal option that was created
to extend Medicaid postpartum benefits
from 60 days which it currently is to
12 months
and the idea from this bill did not come
out of thin air it wasn't the brainchild
of
um you know the person the sponsor of
the bill or our committee this was a
bill that was created by this was an
option that was created by CMS to
address a very specific problem and that
problem is that the United States has a
much higher
maternal mortality rate than other
Western wealthy countries
um
I didn't I didn't bring those notes but
I think the United States was 17.4
[Music]
um
um maternal mortalities
per 100 000 live births a country like
the Czech Republic was four Poland was
one so it's kind of an acknowledged
problem which maybe the doctor will talk
more about
um and so this this option was put into
effect to deal with that problem that we
have in the United States and once again
about 35
states have taken this option I see we
have a map here
um
one of the one of the um one of the
things that um
during our hearings
um another bill which is about a
completely different
um
subject
um which was also um sponsored by um
the chair chair Edwards
um was about
um
the maternal mortality studies that
happened in New Hampshire and um so um
we we got the most recent report and I
looked at that and it said that a great
number of the deaths postpartum occurred
between the period of 43 days and a year
after the birth of a child so I think it
was about 40 percent of the deaths in
New Hampshire not a tremendous amount of
deaths but there it's a problem and
that's why we keep track of it every
year
um
I think another thing to note with this
bill is this will only affect a portion
of people on Medicaid
um
currently
and once again Mr Littman would know the
more specific details but currently
people who are on expanded medicaid
who would get benefits through Medicaid
um
are eligible if they earn 133 percent or
less of the federal poverty level so
anybody on expanded medicaid who
um got pregnant had a child
um
and then reach two months postpartum
they would continue to be on Medicaid by
virtue of the fact that they were
still had a low income
but there's another category of people
who are eligible for Medicaid because
they're pregnant and that goes up to 196
percent of federal poverty level and
it's those people really who
um would lose their Who currently lose
their postpartum benefits after two two
months after birth
um
once again I think this is a bill that
would affect not that many people
but the people it would affect it would
have the effect of strengthening
families supporting children
um
supporting mothers and it's not just the
health care that mothers would continue
to get it's that they it would improve
it would enhance their ability to parent
their children through that first year
of
um life of the children
so I think this is a bill that passed
last year or almost passed last year
this is a bill that strengthens families
and I think this is a bill that we
should pass
Dr Bellinger
good afternoon Mr chair and committee
members my name is Jonathan Ballard I
work
bism boy a-l-l-a-r-d
I work as the chief medical officer for
the Department of Health and Human
Services I'm a family physician by
training
um you know taking care and still
actively and clinically active taking
care of mothers and babies
the I was asked to look at the clinical
rationale for this bill and so in doing
so I look back at what was expressed as
the rationale when it was presented at
the other states I looked at uh so this
is a
coverage that exists in Florida
Mississippi Georgia South Carolina
Indiana Ohio and I believe Governor
Abbott in Texas has proposed it as part
of his budget this year
so it's kind of making its way through
through a number of states and so in New
Hampshire we have had about 3 300 births
for persons who were covered by Medicaid
each year for the past five years and of
that category that representative
Shapiro was
um
was mentioning uh would be around 550 to
750 births of the mothers who would lose
Medicaid coverage now this has not been
an issue for the last three years
because of the continuous Medicaid
enrollment that we were obligated to
maintain uh in order to perceive The
increased Federal match during the
covid-19 pandemic but that is going away
and so then this this has become more of
an issue today than it was last year
so the common medical issues that happen
from Days 60 to the end of the uh year
are numerous I put them in two
categories there's the conditions that
are common that are less severe but may
have impact on the mother and child and
then there are severe conditions that
have you know catastrophic traumatic
outcomes the less severe medical
conditions that happen I see this
commonly uh you know the baby blues we
have a spectrum of the baby blues but
with more severe
um postpartum depression so the baby
blues are common happens around 70
percent of for mothers and there are
proven well-known interventions that can
help they typically they'll last beyond
you know the 60 days so that's one
intervention that the mothers would
receive
the other one is contraceptive care
many
persons or mothers choose to receive
something called an entry uterine device
it's a form of contraception it's a
long-term contraception
um and it's typically though not
eligible in the first 60 days that's
something that we could choose later on
if they would wish to do so the other
thing that hap that's
coverage is for breastfeeding and
lactation support we know a whole host
of outcomes that happen from a clinical
benefits of breastfeeding and what it
has for the immune system of the baby
and for the prevention reduction of
breast cancer risk from other
uh we also see a number of physical
conditions or for mothers I've treated a
number of them who've had you know
chronic pain syndromes uh needed some
additional physical therapy or
occupational therapy to return back to
work the workforce
so that's something that would be uh you
know Common issue that this could be
covered the other common fairly common
is a gestational diabetes is diabetes
during pregnancy
so sometimes that gestational diabetes
goes away sometimes it continues and
their diabetes obviously is a very
expensive disease and has a lot of
clinical outcomes if it's not treated so
Dion 60 days this would be something
that I would expect that this would
benefit would um would be something that
would allow for treatment for
again though less common but very severe
outcomes uh the post-operative
depression or postpartum psychosis
that's very rare but does happen uh and
it could have terrible outcomes as far
as for the mother and child and family
we also see in New Hampshire and across
the country and world uh substance use
disorders opiate use disorders alcohol
use disorder and we also see still a
number of mortalities related to
cardiovascular events even beyond the 60
days so all of these could result in
maternal severe maternal outcomes
including death
from 2018 to 2020 nationally there was 2
273 mothers who died in the Perry
postpartum area and a couple died in New
Hampshire are you able to rescale those
numbers so that we're talking New
Hampshire right from 2018 to 2022
mothers died in New Hampshire in this
category
so this leads to something that is
considered adverse childhood experiences
for for for children in adverse
childhood experiences when the child
experiences a traumatic event like a
loss of a parent separation from a
parent because of uh incarceration or
divorce or or set physical separation
otherwise
uh there's a whole host of other adverse
childhood experiences that we know have
strong connections with their the child
developing their own problems later in
life not only mental health issues but
also physical health conditions even
even chronic diseases
um we know that uh persons who develop
opiate use disorders and overdose deaths
have a strong relationship with adverse
childhood experiences so it's sort of a
generational
intervention that's being proposed today
from my review what's been proposed in
the other states so the idea is that
um
by intervening as early as possible
Upstream providing that uh
mother who is Medicaid eligible
already with the continued service for
the following year that they would
continue to have access to Medical Care
parenting skills parenting classes that
could be covered and help lead to better
outcomes for the but not the mother but
also the the Next Generation and to
break that cycle now New Hampshire is
one of the healthiest states in the
country and we have some of the best
outcomes of Health diseases but in this
area this is something particularly we
recognize in New Hampshire with opiate
use disorder
and suicides that uh that could be of
benefit to help keep us you know at the
top of the country
I think that's that's that's the
clinical rationale
representative Weiler I thank you Mr
chairman what percentage of the births
in New Hampshire are Medicaid births
I don't know the number of that I have
to
I believe it's about 25 thank you
are there other questions
you know Dr Ballard one thank you for
tolerating the fact that I can't
remember your name very well it's old
age slipping in
um and the other for putting together
the clinical presentation side of this
so I
as I'm as I'm listening to you and I'm
trying to understand what the impact
that this um this additional money may
have on making programs available there
there's probably at least three major
categories and you tell me if this is
bad thinking or not there's there's uh
the postpartum uh related to depression
which is you know getting the woman uh
counseling and perhaps some medication
and the other support to help with that
then there are sort of the severe
clinical outcomes the diabetes the
cardiac the those kinds of things and I
would think that even with this program
there would still be a significant
amount of mortality there I I'm just
having a hard time perceiving how this
particular program would reach into that
demographic and and actively change the
numbers maybe you could tell me that and
and then the third category are those
who are committed to substance abuse
that we
he gets we can't do anything about it
because people are just so
self-destructive when they start to go
down the substance abuse chain that this
program
may not really be helping them but maybe
some of the other substance abuse
Outreach efforts might so so those are
kind of the three ways I'm looking at
this in the three big buckets am I is
that is that a fair representation you
think representative Edwards I think
that's an excellent
way to break it out and I think that the
interventions that are available through
Medical Care can prevent you know those
terrible outcomes in all three of those
buckets but if they don't get care and
they don't delay care or they do delay
care then that's
we're going to set ourselves up for a
much more greater expense and and
uh detriment to society a longer term if
we don't during this little critical
window we're speaking about very small
percentage of our Medicaid population
very small percentage of Medicaid
population but a very big impact on our
state on our economy yeah I I I'm
agreeing with you I'm just letting you
know that the other thing that we hear
whispered in our ear is we're
continually expanding Medicaid always
expanding Medicaid one you know this is
the cut by or the death by a Thousand
Cuts and so it's just it just each time
we do one of these we just have to be
very sure why we're doing it is all
representative uh Shapiro I would I I
understand
um
you know I I understand the the
idea that
um that some people who use that abuse
substances
um are not that receptive to help and um
this does not force help on them
um and it it creates the option it
creates the availability for those
services for those who are motivated and
for those who pursue them and um
you know as you said we don't have a
very good track record with um treating
substance use this serious substance use
disorders
um but this makes help available for the
people who
um are motivated and to take it and for
the ones that just
um
not interested then the state's not
going to end up paying for those
services for them
thank you for that I I just as we make
these you know represent a story in just
a second
um
I I guess I just want to make it clear
that when we're when we're funding these
programs we should be doing it from a
realism perspective that we have we're
trying to do unlimited good but we're
probably going to end up having limited
impact and that's just part of this I'd
like to thank you for mentioning my uh
maternal mortality bill I also want to
thank you for not mentioning it went
down 19 to nothing in your committee so
that was really good of you
representative Stringham
now it's hard to follow that up but I I
just want to make sure I understand uh
how this benefit plays out I mean
currently when when a patient who's
delivered two months ago
um they don't lose Medicaid altogether
right there or do they do they do uh
that has not happened in the last three
years but if they are not otherwise in
the income eligible bracket already
um and they got it because of the ex the
higher percentage of the federal poverty
level and because they were pregnant
they would lose it so so in that case
they would have gone back to work
perhaps after having the baby they're
above the the federal poverty level
restriction and now they have no
Medicaid at that point right and this
would be irrespective whether they're
work or not it's it would be thank you
historical information
any other questions representative
solorski thank you I'm just wondering if
Ballard can speak on
the impact to uh if there is a um
a woman who no longer has care 60 days
postpartum and has an unexpected
pregnancy due to lack of care either
contraceptive counseling or whatever if
those snowballing effects if you ever
see that result in
um you know even poorer outcomes
for the family or the mother after the
second birth I guess
I mean I haven't looked into those
demographic chains I can speak from my
own experience being a provider for
patients like that there are several
situations where
where you kind of rush to get everything
done before the 60th day before you know
that they're going to receive those
bills themselves
the IUD is one of the examples so it's
maybe a little too much but
um
when you meet when a mother immediately
gives birth the uterus is
uh you know stretched and it's not a
time period that you want to use an IUD
as the primary form of contraception you
need a waiting period before it's safe
to do so
uh and this is a challenge when the
mother is going to lose health insurance
because then potentially she would no
longer have access to that form of
contraception if that's her primary
choice of for how to use it so then you
start to use less effective forms of
contraception that could result in an
unintended pregnancy
thank you I'm just reflecting on my own
pregnancies at day 60 and how I was
nowhere near ready to uh Take On The
World
so
to keep up with the image of being uh
parsimonious uh is there an amount of
days that we could authorize it doesn't
go all the way to a year where we would
still be hitting the greatest impact
like six months nine months Dr Ballard
from a clinical rationale it's I don't
have the evidence for six months or nine
months right they look at the
intrapartum period is one year
post-pregnancy it's recommended that you
do not become pregnant again for at
least one year after the previous
pregnancy so they sort of look at that
whole period of time as the interpartum
period and that's where the evidence and
the data looks at all right thank you
representative Shapiro
um you're already winning so just be
careful what you say now okay
um
I think Dr Littman has already spoken to
about
um the advisability or not of trying to
adapt the program from 12 months to nine
months or in terms of the expense and
the effort but I I would like to say one
thing and this maybe goes against your
advice but um I'll say it anyway I can't
help myself
um you know I I
I have certain assumptions
um just like everybody we make certain
assumptions about
um
you know people who are wealthy or
people who are poor or people who are on
Medicaid or people who are immigrants
and
um certainly this didn't fit with my
assumptions but when I was um speaking
to Mr Lipman the other day
um he advised me that 70 of the people
on Medicaid in New Hampshire
um are working either part-time or
full-time so I think our I'll say it
about myself
my assumption that people on Medicaid or
people who are
um
you know not out there struggling in
some of the same ways that we are is
um
it's not always the case and certainly I
I understand people's concern that
Medicaid
um can create some kind of depend
dependence and I think that that's from
my experience working as a therapist
with people on Medicaid for many many
years I think there's some reality to
that but I think it's just a small part
of the picture and I think there are
other things about Medicaid policy that
we could change
to alter the incentives for people to
get on with their lives and to um
get more fully employed and make more
money and get
employer-based health care
I'd be happy to work on that bill if you
want to introduce it in January
all right so thank you very much for
coming by uh I think that wraps us up on
uh 565 is there anyone else in the
audience that wanted to speak on 565
all right so we're going to go on to
House Bill 91 I'm going to introduce it
representative Mooney's going to chair
okay good afternoon we'll move right
along to House Bill 91
there is a revised fiscal note that was
distributed by Mr Ripple prior to this
work session so be sure everyone is
aware of that house bill 91 and with
that we'll introduce a very familiar
individual to this division
representative Edwards you're on all
right thank you madam chair uh
representative Jess Edwards District 31
of Rockingham I want to bring forward
House Bill 91 with the amendment that
was just referenced
some of you may recognize this bill this
bill passed in the house very easily
last term it was then taken hostage by
the Senate and was used in a committee a
conference
negotiation that the house did not
accept and so it it died as collateral
damage so I've reintroduced it this term
it did well I think in
in Health and Human Services I believe
it was an 18-2 vote coming out of that
committee I believe this was on a
consent calendar
what does it do it does three things
really two of them are just policy
issues that I would hope that the this
committee wouldn't take issue with and
then there's a money issue that I'll
talk about the first thing it kind of
does
is is it establishes
that there should be a corporate-like
governance structure in the Department
of Health and Human Services looking at
uh privacy issues and they would
invariably I think bring security into
that as well but but it's really a
privacy Focus uh corporations have done
this to make sure that the leadership of
the corporations are intimately involved
and aware of the privacy issues that
their company deals with and so given
that we passed the Constitutional
amendment in 2018 to create a right to
privacy this is just an evolution within
the department to get the leadership
fully engaged in the issue in a
comparable way to the corporate America
the other thing that it does is it
establishes a risk mitigation technique
that's used commonly in Corporate
America it's called I'm most familiar
with it as a private see impact
assessment a privacy impact assessment
evaluates an I.T system for example
before it goes live to to look at it to
determine what its security controls are
what the personal data is it's being
used how it's being used who's using it
how it's going to be stored how it's
going to be encrypted when it's moved or
how it's going to get deleted at the end
of its life and how notifications to the
data the the consumer who owns their
data how how that will be managed those
privacy impact assessments
essentially say okay here's everything
we know about this system here are the
risks that we see and increasingly
they're really more procedural on how to
deal with the data but but whatever the
risk is there should be a mitigation
plan meaning you can you can't get rid
of all risk that's not the world we live
in but if you can identify the risk then
you can mitigate the risk so that the
chances of damage is lowered and so that
privacy impact assessment is is a common
tool
and I'm recommending that the department
use them the um the last part of it is
because the governance board and because
these privacy impact assessments are new
to the department
looked at it and in discussion with the
Department to determine that
there are some unique job qualifications
that the department does not currently
have there's there's a kind of a you
know if you look at a Venn diagram of
three big bubbles somebody has to be
pretty good on I.T security they have to
be really good at privacy
Concepts and then they have to really be
good at project management to go out and
talk to people and to figure out what
should be done in order to address any
issues and so those that that that skill
set's a bit unique in the department so
these two positions were identified as
the appropriate job classifications for
those personnel and that's why there is
a change in the um in the fiscal note
because the job classification was
corrected from the the first go-around
and so I think if the department took or
the department excuse me if this
committee took any issue with any of
this bill it would be about the two
Personnel you know and um and you know
so so somebody had were to propose an
amendment that would be one way to deal
with this but I would certainly want the
policies to be going into effect and
with that I'll take questions
thank you representative Edwards
questions from the committee
all set
the Department's here if you want to
hear from them they came in special just
so that they could present so absolutely
I see Mr Wieters and also
are there
Mr Gillen right
and your title Mr Gillen
good afternoon everyone for the record I
am Ernie Killen my title is deputy
director for Information Services for
Health and Human Services thank you and
that was so expertly presented
I can answer any questions or support if
we have anything from the board
sure I can go ahead and add if there are
any questions at this point sure and
with me is director David Wieters
director of Information Services as well
we were dividing and conquering as he
was presenting a capital budget in a
room down the hall
yeah
sure I'm sorry is that better
great is that better
all right
yes so data privacy and security is an
extremely important aspect of how the
department operates every day
Information Services has worked in
conjunction with the sponsors
surrounding the formation language of
this bill
and looking at the composition of the
board members which includes the Health
and Human Services commissioner as well
as the department of Information
Technology commissioner
and the intended roles and
responsibilities of the board it would
formalize data governance which is an
ongoing effort by the department
improving the privacy and security
components for the citizens of the state
privacy impact assessments are an
important part of data privacy and
security of the data but time consuming
effort
the appropriation of the two positions
with the skill sets identified and
dedicated to support the outline
outlined roles and responsibilities
identified in this bill and specifically
working on privacy impact assessments
um
would certainly be a an enormous
assistance to developing the best
systems possible creating data privacy
and security
all set with your presentation okay Mr
wieders anything to add to that
nope thank you very much for having me
but no I wouldn't I would just be
reiterating what representative Edwards
introduced as well as
Ernie Gillen just presented we did work
in concert with many of the sponsors of
the bill in the previous legislative
session we we believe that this bill
moving forward would enable us to
accomplish data privacy and Security in
a much more intentional way and with
that appropriation would allow us to
actually be able to accomplish those
privacy impact assessments that
representative Edwards introduced thank
you thank you and given the history of
this bill it sounds like you've been
waiting for it for a long time is that
an accurate assessment
um certainly we've we've been working I
think I've been working with
representative Edwards since I started
here in May of 2018 talking about
privacy and security
um so this is something that's part of
um our nature in nit is to maintain
privacy and security but it is the
culmination of long-term efforts of
trying to really not only from an
executive branch but also a legislative
branch
um come to come together and figure out
how we can achieve our goals of
providing good services to our citizens
and individuals in our state but with
privacy
in mind as well as the security
very good any further questions
representative Stringham do you uh
foresee these or people that you have
available that you would reassign from
other areas or do you think this would
be new hires and how would that impact
uh how quickly you'd get started
thank you for the question certainly
they would be new hires on the The
Challenge right now so Information
Services on the group that I manage is
five people we have one information
security officer we have one privacy
officer that's not in my my Bureau and
those are the two Primary people focus
on privacy and security this would
expand it essentially increase it by a
hundred percent so it allow us to
achieve things much more quickly in
concert with Department of information
Technologies but we would be recruiting
them
the the titles as they are listed in the
bill and the grade level and step level
is it commensurate with what we have
recently in the last year year and a
half have seen that we can successfully
recruit into and that was part of the
commitment of working with the sponsors
of this bill
that instead of starting it off at like
a grade 29 step one where not many
people would apply for those jobs we we
went and did our own research internally
said when we hire an information
technology manager for at step five we
have been successful at recruiting those
people and did I hit that wrong
Ernie it's going to correct me
step seven sorry we have been able to
recruit those positions effectively
it's been difficult in the pandemic but
it's increasingly difficult not only for
public sector but for private sector
right now in the I.T Fields so having
that position those positions
appropriated at those levels give us the
opportunity to get those and one night
to give me a time frame I would say
that's about six to eight week time
frame to recruit
well follow up can you um just comment
it all about uh kind of how you see this
working is this like something that gets
added on to uh every uh you know
electronic information exchange system
that we have and it's a maybe a module
on there or is this something you see
operating independently in Standalone
where you go out and kind of check all
the opportunities for data breaches
there's a little bit of both hand on on
the answer to that so the Privacy impact
assessment right now we actually
introduce into our standard boilerplate
contracts it says that we can at any
time
require a privacy impact assessment be
performed on any of our contracts and we
we implemented that about a year ago
the actual security assessments are also
in our standard boilerplate where we can
do an audit on any of our vendors at any
time they're required to provide us
different information
sometimes it takes them some time like
if we ask for a sock 2 report or if we
ask for different types of reports they
might be in the process of doing those
and they need to notify us as that
um we also will do the sort of ad hoc
when if there's an issue if there's some
challenges with the system we will then
also dig in a little bit deeper so it's
not uh
everyday thing but it is always at the
time of of instantiating a contract it
would be again done when we terminate a
contract with the vendor to make sure
that we get our data destroyed or or we
or we get the data into our environment
and then they destroy it on their side
because that's part of the contracts as
well contract agreements and then
throughout we will do different
assessments as needed based off of
many different lenses and perspectives
and reasons hopefully that answered your
question
did thank you
thank you any further questions your
presentation is quite timely we just had
a presentation of our own this morning
regarding classifications levels and
grades and so it fits together quite
nicely you picked the perfect day well
or we did all right thank you both
gentlemen if there are no further
questions anyone else in the audience
here to talk or testify or contribute to
house bill 91.
all right with that we'll close 91
representative Edwards you're welcome
back up
all right any further uh questions or
comments we are meeting tomorrow
um that's been published in the calendar
so we'll meet tomorrow at 10 o'clock and
then again at one o'clock to discuss
House Bill 527 I also want to make
mention we're meeting tomorrow in room
104. so no one in this room but
downstairs
anything to close up
looking ahead for the rest of the week
can we I just wanted to clarify
Wednesday I have us starting at one
o'clock is that correct
with that is correct veterans home okay
and then on Friday at all at two o'clock
again
division of economic stability
correct okay just making sure that those
mornings I was checking and then I do
remember we have a house session on
Thursday yes
all right thank you all very much we'll
close this work session for today thank
you